THAT'S A POSITIVE. GOOD. GOOD,
GOOD MORNING, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON REVENUE AND TAXATION WILL
COME TO ORDER. APPRECIATE YOU
ALL BEING HERE. APOLOGIES FOR
STARTING LATE, MANY OF THE
MEMBERS HAVE CONFLICTED
SCHEDULES THIS MORNING WITH
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HAPPENING AT
THE SAME TIME. AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'VE FALLEN INTO TODAY, LET ME
NOTE FOR THE RECORD THAT, ITEM
NUMBER TWO, ASSEMBLY BILL 1973
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY WAS ON
CONSENT. IT'S BEEN PULLED FROM
CONSENT. AND WE'LL HEAR THAT
BILL IN JUST A FEW MINUTES. WE
DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM, SO WE WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO BEGIN AS A
COMMITTEE. WE'LL BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE, AND WITH THAT, I
WANT TO INVITE, SENATOR LOWE,
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER FIVE, AB
2238 BY SENATOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOWE. I DIDN'T SAY CONGRESSMAN.
I ONLY HAVE ONE OTHER CHOICE
LEFT, WHAT WAS THAT? WAIT A
SECOND. HAS THAT GOT DEMOTED?
YES. OKAY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
TODAY AND FOR YOUR WITNESSES.
PATIENCE TODAY. WE'RE PREPARED
TO HEAR YOUR BILL. YOU CAN BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR. AND
COLLEAGUES, AS I ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT MANY
OF US ARE RUNNING AROUND, AND SO
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. YES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. SIMILARLY TO THE
CHAIR. THANK YOU AGAIN ALSO FOR
A ROBUST CONVERSATION WITH
RESPECT TO THE BILL BEFORE YOU,
WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2238,
WHICH WOULD ADD THE STATE
TREASURER AND LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR TO THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD. AND OF COURSE, WHEN THIS
WAS BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION
ABOUT THE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY, I WAS ELATED TO
BE ABLE TO AUTHOR THIS
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL. AND OF
COURSE, I KNOW THAT FOR
ADDITIONAL INSIGHTS, WE'LL BE
HEARING FROM OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICER, STATE TREASURER FIONA
MA HERSELF, WHO HAS ALSO TAKEN
TIME OUT OF HER BUSY SCHEDULE TO
BE WITH US HERE TODAY. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
WHEN YOU AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, AND WE WELCOME OUR STATE
TREASURER. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. AND AGAIN, OUR APOLOGIES
FOR BEING LATE TO START. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, SENATOR. SENATORS,
FOR HEARING THIS BILL, THIS IS
MY SIXTH YEAR AS STATE
TREASURER. SO I KIND OF
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW
THROUGH MY OFFICE. AND WE'VE
GONE THROUGH GOOD TIMES. WE'VE
GONE THROUGH COVID, AND NOW
WE'RE GOING THROUGH DEFICIT
TIMES. I CHAIR 18 BOARDS,
COMMISSIONS AND AUTHORITIES
THROUGH MY OFFICE ALONE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF FINANCE.
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF FINANCE, AS
WELL AS THE COMPTROLLER AND
MYSELF ARE ON ALL THREE OF THOSE
BOARDS. I TAKE IN $3.7 TRILLION
OF REVENUES EVERY YEAR. MY SHORT
TERM PORTFOLIO IS ABOUT 200
BILLION. I ISSUE ALL THE BONDS
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, AND
I SIT ON ALL OF THE FINANCIAL
BOARDS EXCEPT THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD, WHICH I FEEL LIKE IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT BOARD SINCE OUR
STATE IS SO HIGHLY DEPENDENT ON
PERSONAL INCOME TAX AND
CORPORATE CORPORATE, CORPORATE
INCOME TAXES. AND I'M NOT ON
THAT COMMITTEE. SO I DON'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO, PROACTIVELY ASK
THOSE QUESTIONS AND SOMETIMES
IT'S MACROECONOMIC QUESTIONS
LIKE, HOW MANY OF THE ONE
PERCENTERS ARE ACTUALLY LEAVING
THE STATE? HOW MANY OF THEM ARE
FILING YOUR TAX RETURNS? HOW
MANY CORPORATIONS ARE COMING TO
THIS STATE OR LEAVING THE STATE,
WHICH IS WHAT WE HEARD OF, WHICH
IS PART OF THE PROBLEM. AND THEN
MOST RECENTLY WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT POSTPONING THE
DEADLINE FOR FILING, THAT COULD
HAVE BEEN A POLICY QUESTION THAT
WE COULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
RESPOND TO SINCE WE ARE SO
CLOSELY ALIGNED WITH OUR CASH
FLOW AND CASH INVESTMENT. SO,
YOU KNOW, JUST BEING ON THE
BOARD WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL FOR
MYSELF. BUT FUTURE TREASURERS TO
HAVE THAT MONTHLY MEETING, TO BE
ABLE TO ASK THOSE QUESTIONS.
STAFF MEMBERS DO TALK, BUT IT'S
NOT ABOUT, YOU KNOW, HEY, WHAT
IS GOING ON FOR THE NEXT THREE
MONTHS? THE NEXT SIX MONTHS,
WHEN ARE WE GOING TO GET OUT OF
THIS DEFICIT? AND IF THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD HAS ISSUES
THAT THEY NEED TO RUN BY A
POLICY COMMITTEE, THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE SHOULD BE ON
THAT BOARD. SO, FOR GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY, GOOD GOVERNMENT
TRANSPARENCY, THE ABILITY TO,
HAVE THE TREASURER, YOU KNOW,
HAVE THAT, THAT MORE, CURRENT
UPDATE ON WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH
THOSE IMPORTANT REVENUE SOURCES,
WOULD GREATLY HELP, NOT ONLY THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE, BUT ADVISE
ALL OF YOU, THE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR WAS ADDED BECAUSE THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR CHAIRS THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION FOR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT, WHICH
PROVIDES SUPPORT AND GUIDANCE TO
THE GOVERNOR, LEGISLATIVE AND
PRIVATE SECTOR REGARDING
DEVELOPMENT OF CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY AND HER NOT ALSO
UNDERSTANDING WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN THE PERSONAL AND CORPORATION
TAX WORLD ALSO GIVES HER A
DISADVANTAGE IN TERMS OF BEING
ABLE TO BE THAT SPOKESPERSON OR
THAT ADVISOR ON ISSUES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT TO, YOU KNOW, WHETHER
WE'RE IN A DEFICIT, OUT OF A
DEFICIT, WHERE WE'RE GOING
TRENDS, ETC. SO THAT'S WHY I,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. TREASURER. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES THAT YOU HAVE?
PRIMARY WITNESSES. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I DON'T BELIEVE SO. THIS,
SO WE'LL OPEN IT UP TO OTHERS
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE THEIR
POSITION OF SUPPORT, NAME AND
AFFILIATION. GOOD MORNING.
GENESIS GONZALEZ, ON BEHALF OF
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR ELENI
KOUNALAKIS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GREAT. ANYONE ELSE IN THE
HEARING ROOM IN SUPPORT? SEEING
NONE, WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. IS
THERE ANYBODY WHO IS HERE IN
OPPOSITION THAT WANTS TO GIVE
PRIMARY TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION,
NOT SEEN ANYBODY, ANYONE WANT TO
COME TO THE MIC AND DO ANY TWOS
IN OPPOSITION NOT SEEING ANYONE.
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
SENATOR BRADFORD, ANY QUESTIONS
FOR YOU? I DON'T HAVE ANY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU. TREASURER. THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE. THANK YOU. SO WE
HAVE A QUORUM. WE'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY. THANK YOU. OKAY. I DON'T
KNOW WHO WAS HERE FIRST. MR.
LACKEY, MR. LACKEY OKAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY. SO WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NOW TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO. THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL 1973 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY, SIR, THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. WE WELCOME YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY. WELL, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT, AB 1973, THE
BOBCAT FIRE OF 2020 TORE THROUGH
THE ANGELES NATIONAL FOREST,
DESTROYING OVER 115,000 ACRES OF
PRECIOUS LAND AND BURNING THE
HOMES AND LIVELIHOODS OF MANY.
THE TOLL OF THIS TRAGEDY IS
IMMEASURABLE, AND THE SCARS IS
LEFT UPON. OUR COMMUNITY ARE
VERY DEEP AND ENDURING. HOWEVER
NOW THE FOLLOWING SETTLEMENT NOW
FOLLOWING THE SETTLEMENT, MY
CONSTITUENTS MUST FACE ATTACKS
ON THE PAYMENTS THAT THEY ARE
INTENDED TO THAT WERE GIVEN TO
THEM, INTENDED TO ALLEVIATE
THEIR LOSSES. TO ME, IT'S CRUEL
IRONY THAT THOSE WHO HAVE
ALREADY ENDURED SO MUCH MUST NOW
SHOULDER THE BURDEN OF TAXATION
ON THEIR JOURNEY TOWARDS
REBUILDING THEIR LIVES. AB 1973
WILL ENSURE THAT THOSE WELL
DESERVED SETTLEMENT PAYMENTS ARE
RECEIVED IN THEIR FULL AMOUNTS,
AND WOULD BE EXEMPT FROM
TAXATION. THIS LEGISLATION DRAWS
UPON THE PRECEDENT SET BY SENATE
BILL 1246 AND AB 1249, WHICH
PROVIDED SIMILAR EXEMPTIONS FOR
VICTIMS OF PAST WILDFIRES SUCH
AS THE CAMPFIRE, THE THOMAS FIRE
AND WOOLSEY FIRE. BY PASSING AB
1973, WE NOT ONLY PROVIDE
CRUCIAL FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO
THOSE WHO HAVE LOST EVERYTHING
IN THE BOBCAT FIRE, BUT ALSO
REAFFIRM OUR COMMITMENT TO
STANDING WITH COMMUNITIES IN
THEIR TIME OF NEED. AND THAT'S
MY TESTIMONY. THANK YOU SIR, ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT DO YOU HAVE
HERE TODAY? NO, WE JUST LEARNED
THAT WE WERE GOING TO HAVE TO DO
PRESENTATION A SHORT TIME AGO. I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE I ASK
APPROPRIATELY. DOES ANYONE HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE THEIR POSITION OF
SUPPORT? PLEASE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE. SEEING NONE, WE'LL
GO TO OPPOSITION. ANYONE HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM IN OPPOSITION,
SEEING NONE. WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS, SENATOR
LACKEY, I SUPPORT YOUR BILL.
IT'S CONSISTENT WITH WHAT WE
HAVE DONE AS A STATE IN THE
PAST, AND I THINK IT'S ONLY
APPROPRIATE THAT WE, HAVE THIS
TYPE OF A REMEDY FOR THOSE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN SO HURT BY
BY THOSE FIRES. SO WHEN WE HAVE
A QUORUM, WE'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. SIR. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
DO YOU WANT TO CLOSE ANYTHING
YOU WANT TO SAY IN CLOSING? NO.
YOU DID A GOOD JOB OF DOING IT
FOR ME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. BYE BYE. THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIN. YOU'VE
BEEN VERY PATIENT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE, WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NOW TO FILE ITEM 12.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 3134.
AGAIN, APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE
AND YOU MAY BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
SENATOR BRADFORD FOR ONCE AGAIN
SAVING THE DAY FOR ALLOWING US
TO START. YOU LOOK VERY HANDSOME
TODAY BY THE WAY. YOU LOOK GOOD
IN A FIREMAN'S OUTFIT, DON'T YOU
THINK? IT'S VERY ATTRACTIVE?
AGAIN. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, FOR
YOUR TIME AND FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT AB 3134. I FIRST WANT TO
THANK YOUR INCREDIBLE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH MY TEAM ON THIS
BILL, EXISTING LAW AUTHORIZES
REFUND OF TAXES OR ASSESSMENTS
AS A RESULT OF REDUCTION IN THE
VALUE OF TAXABLE PROPERTY OR
SPECIFIED CORRECTIONS TO BE PAID
TO THE LATEST RECORDED OWNER OF
THAT PROPERTY, AS SHOWN ON THE
TAX ROLL. IF THERE HAS BEEN NO
TRANSFER OF THE PROPERTY DURING
OR SINCE THE FISCAL YEAR, WHICH
THE TAX IS SUBJECT TO REFUND
WERE LEVIED IN, THE AMOUNT OF
THE REFUND IS LESS THAN $5,000.
UNDER EXISTING LAW, THE COUNTY
MAY AUTHORIZE TO BE PAID A
REFUND OF TAXES OR ASSESSMENTS
WITHOUT CLAIM FOR REFUND FILED
TO THE ASSESSEE OF THAT
PROPERTY. IF THERE HAS BEEN NO
TRANSFER OF THE PROPERTY DURING
THE WAR. SINCE THE FISCAL YEAR
FOR WHICH THE TAX IS SUBJECT TO
REFUND WERE LEVIED, THE AMOUNT
OF THE REFUND IS LESS THAN
$5,000. AB 3134 WOULD TAKE
IMPORTANT STEPS TO EXPEDITE THE
PAYMENT OF THE PROPERTY TAX AND
ASSESSMENTS. REFUNDS TO
TAXPAYERS. THIS MEASURE WOULD
INCREASE THE EXISTING $5,000 CAP
FOR AUTOMATIC REFUNDS WITHOUT A
CLAIM REQUIRED TO $10,000.
CAPTURING A LARGER UNIVERSE OF
CLAIMS THAT CAN BE IMMEDIATELY
DISPERSED TO TAXPAYERS. THIS
BILL WOULD ALSO AUTHORIZE AN
ORDER FOR REFUND OF TAXES OR
ASSESSMENTS TO BE PAID TO A
DISABLED VETERAN OR VETERAN'S
SURVIVING SPOUSE WITHOUT CLAIM
FOR REFUND FILED IF THE REFUND
IS DUE TO THE DISABLED VETERANS
EXEMPTION. LASTLY, THIS MEASURE
WOULD PROVIDE A REASONABLE LIMIT
FOR ACCRUED INTEREST PAYMENTS ON
THE AMOUNTS DUE TO TAXPAYER WHO
HAS BEEN PROVIDED TIMELY NOTICE
HERE TO TESTIFY WITH ME, WE HAVE
CHAD RINDY, WHO IS THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY FINANCE
DIRECTOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND YOU MAY BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY, CHAD RINDY,
REPRESENTING THE STATE
ASSOCIATION OF AUDITOR
COMPTROLLERS TODAY. THANK YOU,
SENATORS, FOR YOUR TIME. AS
STATED, THIS BILL IS INTENDED TO
STREAMLINE OUR PROPERTY TAX
REFUND PROCESS TO ALLOW MORE
SITUATIONS WHERE WE DO NOT
REQUIRE CLAIMS OR ADDITIONAL
PAPERWORK FROM TAXPAYERS BEFORE
WE ARE ABLE TO PRODUCE THOSE
REFUNDS AND REMIT THEM TO THEM,
INCLUDING SITUATIONS THE
ASSEMBLYMAN HAS DESCRIBED FOR
DISABLED VETERANS. INCREASING
THE THRESHOLD FROM 5000 TO
10,000 FOR AUTOMATIC REFUNDS AND
THE SITUATION OF PUBLIC
ACQUISITION OF PROPERTY. THIS
WOULD BENEFIT NOT ONLY THE
AUDITOR, COMPTROLLER OFFICES TO
MAKE OUR OFFICES MORE EFFICIENT.
IN DOING THIS CRITICAL TASK, BUT
ALSO TO GET MONIES OWED BACK TO
OUR TAXPAYERS OUT IN A MORE
EXPEDIENT MANNER. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS SMALL
BUT IMPORTANT MEASURE TO IMPROVE
OUR PROPERTY TAX SYSTEM. I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES WHO WANT TO INDICATE
THEIR SUPPORT? COME ON UP TO THE
MICROPHONE. CLIFTON WILSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY TREASURERS
AND TAX COLLECTORS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, SIR ERIC LARA, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM IN SUPPORT? ALL RIGHT.
ANYONE HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
IN OPPOSITION WANT TO COME
FORWARD? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE. WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHEN, THANK YOU FOR WORKING ON
THIS BILL. IT'S SOMETHING I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT TODAY. WHEN WE
HAVE A QUORUM, WE'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR, THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE LOOKING FOR
AUTHORS HERE IN SENATE REVENUE
AND TAXATION. SO FOR STAFF WHO
ARE LISTENING AND MEMBERS WHO
MAY BE WATCHING, PLEASE COME ON
DOWN SO WE CAN HEAR YOUR BILL
AND TAKE CARE OF OUR BUSINESS
THIS MORNING. OKAY? WE'LL BE IN
SHORT RECESS.
ALL RIGHT. THE, THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON REVENUE AND
TAXATION WILL COME BACK TO
ORDER, WE ARE GOING TO NEXT HEAR
FILE ITEM TEN. THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL 2854 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN, WE HAVE A PERMISSION
LETTER FROM HER TO HAVE HER
STAFF MEMBER, WESLEY WHITAKER,
PRESENT ON HER BEHALF. THIS IS A
BIG MOMENT FOR MR. WHITAKER. I'M
SURE WE'LL ALL EVALUATE AND SEE
HOW HE DOES. WE'LL GIVE A REPORT
INTO THE ASSEMBLYWOMAN. MR.
WHITAKER, WE WELCOME YOU ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYWOMAN IRWIN.
HAVE YOU EVER DONE THIS BEFORE.
NO, SIR. WELL, WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY. THANK YOU. THIS IS
EXCITING FOR YOU. SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN, THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU. MR. CHAIR AND SENATORS,
TODAY I'M PRESENTING ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN AB
2854, WHICH WILL BRING MUCH
NEEDED TRANSPARENCY TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT REVENUES UNDER YOUR
LEADERSHIP. MR. CHAIR, THIS
COMMITTEE HAS ALREADY DUG INTO
THIS ISSUE EARLIER THIS YEAR. SO
I'LL SPARE YOU ALL SOME OF THE
THORNY DETAILS ABOUT EXACTLY HOW
SALES TAXES ARE ALLOCATED AMONG
OUR CITIES. BUT IT SUFFICES TO
SAY THAT UNDER EXISTING LAW,
RETAILERS WITH MULTIPLE PLACES
OF BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA CAN
ORGANIZE THEIR OPERATIONS IN
SUCH A WAY THAT THE LOCAL
PORTION OF THEIR SALES TAXES
THAT THEY COLLECT AND REMIT CAN
BE FUNNELED TO ONE JURISDICTION
IN EXCHANGE, BUSINESSES WILL
ENTER INTO AN AGREEMENT WITH
THAT JURISDICTION TO GET A
PORTION OF THOSE SALES TAXES
REBATED BACK TO THEM. THIS CAN
PIT CITIES AND COUNTIES AGAINST
ONE ANOTHER IN A ZERO SUM GAME,
WHERE THE JURISDICTION THAT HAS
AN AGREEMENT WITH THE BUSINESS
SEES AN INCREASE IN OVERALL
REVENUE AT THE EXPENSE OF MANY
OTHER JURISDICTIONS AT THE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ORGANIZED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN ON THIS
TOPIC LAST FALL, SHE HEARD
FIRSTHAND FROM CITY LEADERS
ABOUT THE IMPACTS OF THESE
AGREEMENTS, INCLUDING IN CITIES
THAT HISTORICALLY HAVE BENEFITED
FROM THEM LIKE THE CITY OF
FRESNO, THE CITY MANAGER FOR
SIMI VALLEY TESTIFIED AT THE
HEARING, AND EXPLAINED HOW THEIR
COMMUNITIES ROADS ARE IN A
CONSTANT STATE OF DISREPAIR DUE
TO A STEADY STREAM OF HEAVY
TRUCKS ENTERING AND EXITING A
CONCRETE BATCH PLANT IN THE CITY
. DESPITE THESE AND OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS, THE CITY
OF SIMI VALLEY DOESN'T RECEIVE A
SINGLE CENT OF BRADLEY BYRNE'S
REVENUE FROM THESE CONCRETE
SALES BECAUSE ALL SALES MADE BY
THAT CONCRETE MANUFACTURER ARE
BOOKED OUT OF ONE SALES OFFICE
IN A CITY THAT IS MILES AWAY
FROM ANY OTHER BATCH PLANTS AND
THE ASSOCIATED IMPACTS. WHILE AB
2854 DOES NOT CHANGE A CITY'S
ABILITY TO ENTER INTO ANY OF
THESE KINDS OF AGREEMENTS, IT
DOES, HOWEVER, ADVANCE A KEY
POLICY RECOMMENDATION THAT IS
ENDORSED BY A BROAD CROSS
SECTION OF CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
COUNTIES. BECAUSE THE ONLY
INFORMATION WE CURRENTLY HAVE IS
THE RESULT FROM STORIES OF A FEW
TENACIOUS REPORTERS, THE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION
EVEN HELD A WEBINAR ON MAY 14TH,
WHERE ONE OF THEIR PANELISTS
ADMITTED THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE
NO IDEA HOW MANY OF THESE
AGREEMENTS ARE IN PLACE OR HOW
MUCH REVENUE IS BEING REBATED
ANNUALLY. BY REQUIRING CITIES TO
SUBMIT THIS INFORMATION ANNUALLY
TO THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION,
POLICY MAKERS AT BOTH THE STATE
AND LOCAL LEVELS WILL BE BETTER
EQUIPPED TO DECIDE WHETHER THE
CLAIMED BENEFITS FROM THESE
AGREEMENTS ARE WORTH THE LOSS.
IN CRUCIAL TAX REVENUE. HERE
WITH US TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF PLACENTIA IS DAMIEN
URRUELA. THANK YOU, MR.
WHITAKER. DID YOU WRITE THOSE
REMARKS? I DID YOU READ THEM?
VERY WELL. THANK YOU. WE WELCOME
YOUR WITNESS. THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY. THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD MORNING, HONORABLE CHAIR
GLAZER AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS DAMIEN
NARULA, AND I HAVE THE HONOR OF
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
PLACENTIA IN ORANGE COUNTY TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2854 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN
PLACENTIA'S. POPULATION IS
APPROXIMATELY 51,000. AND WE ARE
ONE OF THE OLDEST CITIES IN
ORANGE COUNTY. WE'RE ABOUT TO
CELEBRATE OUR CENTENNIAL
ANNIVERSARY AND OUR NEWLY BUILT
OUT WITH LIMITED OPPORTUNITIES
FOR INDUSTRIAL AND RETAIL
GROWTH. LIKE MANY CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA, WE ARE PRIMARILY A
BEDROOM COMMUNITY WITH LIMITED
COMMERCIAL, RETAIL, INDUSTRIAL,
AND HOTEL USES. WE HAVE NO SALES
TAX REBATE AGREEMENTS WITH ANY
BUSINESSES IN OUR CITY AND RELY
ON SALES AND USE TAX GENERATED
FROM TRADITIONAL SOURCES. WHILE
WE HAVE COMMERCIAL RETAIL, THESE
AREAS ARE RELATIVELY SMALL
RETAIL CENTERS LIKE MOST
COMMUNITIES, AND WE DON'T HAVE
WHAT I REFER TO AS A RETAIL
DESTINATION DRIVER, WHICH CAN BE
DIFFICULT TO PROVIDE A NORDSTROM
LEVEL OF CUSTOMER SERVICE BASED
UPON THE CURRENT SALES TAX
LANDSCAPE. I SHARE ALL OF THIS
WITH YOU TO SIMPLY INDICATE THAT
I BELIEVE PLACENTIA IS A GOOD
REPRESENTATION AND BAROMETER OF
MANY COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THAT MAY NOT HAVE A
LARGE RETAIL DESTINATION,
HOTELS, OR ANY OTHER USES THAT
MAY GENERATE ADDITIONAL REVENUE.
I ALSO WANTED TO BRIEFLY GIVE
YOU AN UPDATE ON HOW COMMUNITIES
LIKE PLACENTIA HAVE HAD TO
RESPOND TO AND ADDRESS THESE
IMPACTS FROM THE EXISTING
BRADLEY BYRNE SALES TAX
LANDSCAPE. THESE ACTIONS INCLUDE
PASSING A 1% TRANSACTIONS AND
USE TAX. IN OUR CITY, IT'S KNOWN
AS MEASURE U AND NOVEMBER 2018
WAS ESSENTIALLY THE SAME 1% AS
THE BRADLEY BURNS SALES TAX. THE
ALLOCATION OF TRANSACTIONS AND
USE TAXES ARE VASTLY DIFFERENT
IN CALIFORNIA AND ARE MORE
FAVORABLE FOR BEDROOM CITIES
LIKE PLACENTIA, AS THE ENTIRE 1%
IS ALLOCATED TO THE CITY OF
PLACENTIA AND IS NOT DISTRIBUTED
TO OTHER AGENCIES VIA THE COUNTY
OR STATE POOL. IN ADDITION,
AUTOMOBILES PURCHASED BY
PLACENTIA RESIDENTS OUTSIDE THE
CITY ARE SUBJECT TO THE 1%
TRANSACTIONS TAX. AT THE TIME OF
PURCHASE, REGARDLESS OF WHERE
THE VEHICLE IS PURCHASED FROM.
THE CITY WHERE THE DEALERSHIP
RESIDES. COLLECTS THE BRADLEY
BURNS TAX, BUT PLACENTIA
RECOVERS THE FULL 1%
TRANSACTIONS AND USE TAX. IT
SHOULD BE NOTED THAT PLACENTIA
SUPPORTS THE EQUITY STATEMENT
AND SERIES OF POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS ON SALES TAX
AGREEMENTS PUT FORTH BY THE
BIPARTISAN CITY MANAGER SALES
TAX WORKING GROUP, PUT TOGETHER
BY THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES, OF WHICH I WAS A PART
OF. WHILE WE SUPPORT THE CITY
MANAGER WORKING GROUP'S
BIPARTISAN RECOMMENDATIONS ON
SALES TAX AGREEMENTS, PLACENTIA
BELIEVES THAT MORE TRANSPARENCY
AROUND SALES TAX AGREEMENTS IS
NEEDED IN ORDER TO CRAFT THE
BEST PUBLIC POLICY POSSIBLE,
GIVEN THE WIDE RANGE OF
STAKEHOLDERS. THIS BILL DOES NOT
CREATE WINNERS AND LOSERS. THIS
BILL SIMPLY PUTS EVERYONE ON AN
EQUAL PLAYING FIELD OF
INFORMATION TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
AND GUIDE THE LEGISLATURE ON HOW
FUTURE PUBLIC POLICY DECISIONS
REGARDING SALES TAX ALLOCATIONS
COULD POTENTIALLY ADDRESS ALL
COMMUNITIES NEEDS. IT IS. IT IS
A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
THAT WILL ALLOW US TO EXAMINE
HOW TO CONTINUE TO IMPROVE SALES
TAX REFORM IN FUTURE YEARS FOR
COMMUNITIES SUCH AS PLACENTIA
AND MANY OTHERS. TO WRAP UP, I
WOULD SAY THAT GOOD BIPARTISAN
TRANSPARENCY MEASURES ARE
DEFINITELY NEEDED ON SALES TAX
AGREEMENTS, AND WE SUPPORT THE
COMMENTS MADE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ERWIN. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY AND
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF AB 2854 AS
WE WORK TOGETHER TO IMPROVE
SALES TAX REFORM FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. ALL RIGHT.
ANYBODY HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL TO PLEASE
COME TO THE MICROPHONE? ANYONE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM? OKAY.
WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION. ANYONE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WANT TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION?
PLEASE COME FORWARD. SEEING
NONE, WE'LL BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. NO
QUESTIONS THERE. SAY AGAIN.
YEAH, YEAH, I THINK YOU SHOULD.
TRY MY BEST. ALL RIGHT. MR.
WHITAKER, THANK YOU FOR THE
TERRIFIC PRESENTATION, REALLY
GOOD. DID YOU READ EVERYTHING ON
THOSE NOTES, OR DID YOU TAKE
SOME THINGS OUT AS YOU WERE
SPEAKING, I MODIFIED A COUPLE
PLACES. THAT JUST SHOWS YOU
YOU'RE READY TO ELEVATE INTO THE
POSITION ITSELF. SO THE STAFF
DOESN'T ALWAYS HAVE IT RIGHT
WHEN YOU'RE PRESENTING. USUALLY
MY BOSS CROSSES A FEW THINGS
OUT, SO I'M JUST TRYING TO BE
CONSISTENT. TERRIFIC. I'M, THANK
YOU FOR TO HER FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD, AS YOU KNOW, QUITE
WELL, I THINK THAT, THAT THIS
TAX SYSTEM THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY FOR IS IN
MANY WAYS CORRUPT, IT IT DOES
CREATE A SERIES OF WINNERS AND
LOSERS. THE WINNERS ARE ABOUT 7%
OF THE CITIES, AND THE LOSERS
ARE ABOUT 93, AND IT ALLOWS,
MORE THAN $1 BILLION IN TAXPAYER
MONEY. THAT WOULD GO FOR PUBLIC
SERVICES TO BE GIVEN BACK TO
THESE COMPANIES THAT HAVE
MANIPULATED THIS TAX CODE. SO
YOU'RE CERTAINLY IN THE SWEET
SPOT FOR ME, AS YOU KNOW, IN A
PLACE THAT REQUIRES SIGNIFICANT
REFORM, MORE SO THAN EVEN WHAT'S
IN THIS BILL. BUT OBVIOUSLY,
WHAT'S IN THIS BILL IS PRUDENT
AND APPROPRIATE. AND WHEN WE
HAVE A QUORUM, WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE A MOTION TO
HOPEFULLY ADVANCE IT. ANYTHING
YOU WANT TO SAY IN YOUR CLOTHES,
JUST, THANK YOU AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. YOU DIDN'T
HAVE A WRITTEN CLOSE THAT ONE. I
HAD MEMORIZED. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU, SIR. THANKS FOR COMING.
THANK YOU. AND YOU DID GREAT.
WE'RE GOING TO PUT IT IN THE
EVALUATION. THAT'S AN A-PLUS.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE LOOKING FOR
AUTHORS HERE IN THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON REVENUE AND
TAXATION. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
SHORT RECESS WHILE WE WAIT FOR
AUTHORS.
WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON REVENUE AND
TAXATION BACK TO ORDER. WE HAVE
A WONDERFUL AUTHOR HERE IN THE
ROOM. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
FILE ITEM EIGHT. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2555 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA. THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE. AND WE WELCOME
YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR AND SENATORS, TODAY I
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2555. THIS
BILL EXTENDS CURRENT TAX
EXEMPTION LAWS ON MEDICINAL
CANNABIS DONATIONS FOR
CHRONICALLY ILL MEDICAL PATIENTS
AND VETERANS UNTIL JANUARY 1ST,
2030. IN 1996, CALIFORNIA VOTERS
PASSED PROPOSITION 215, WHICH
ALLOWED INDIVIDUALS WITH CHRONIC
MEDICAL CONDITIONS TO LAWFULLY
OBTAIN CANNABIS FOR MEDICINAL
PURPOSES. THIS ENABLED PEOPLE
SUFFERING FROM HIV AIDS,
GLAUCOMA, CANCER, AND
POST-TRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER
TO USE CANNABIS TO HELP
ALLEVIATE THEIR SYMPTOMS AND
2016 CALIFORNIA'S VOTERS AGAIN
PASSED PROP 64, WHICH APPROVED
CANNABIS FOR ADULT USE. SB 34,
AUTHORED BY SENATOR WIENER IN
2020, ESTABLISHED A CLEAR PATH
FOR COMPASSIONATE CARE PROGRAMS
ALLOWING CANNABIS LICENSES TO
DONATE CANNABIS AND CANNABIS
PRODUCTS TO LOW INCOME PATIENTS
AND VETERANS, AND EXEMPTING
THESE PRODUCTS FROM TAXATION
UNTIL JANUARY 2025. WITH THIS
SUNSET DATE TO RAPIDLY
APPROACHING, AB 2555 WILL EXTEND
THE TAX EXEMPTION ON DONATED
CANNABIS PRODUCT PRODUCTS FOR
ANOTHER FIVE YEARS. AND WITH ME
TODAY WE HAVE RICHARD MILLER, A
PATIENT ADVOCATE, ON BEHALF OF
AMERICANS FOR SAFE ACCESS AND
JOY, CASSIOPEIA. CASSIOPEIA US
ARMY VETERAN AND MEMBER OF
COMPASSIONATE VETERANS TO MAKE
COMMENTS. GREAT. WELL, THANK
YOU, ASSEMBLYWOMAN, FOR
PRESENTING THE BILL. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM YOUR
WITNESSES. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
EACH. WHO WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN?
THAT'S ME. GOOD MORNING.
CHAIRMAN GLAZER AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS JOY LILY
CASSIOPEIA. I'M A DISABLED ARMY
VETERAN AND SACRAMENTO RESIDENT.
I AM AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF
COMPASSIONATE VETERANS AND A
MEDICAL PATIENT WHO RELIES ON
THE DONATED PRODUCTS I RECEIVE
THROUGH THE SB 34 COMPASSION
PROGRAMS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
DURING MY SERVICE, I DEPENDED ON
VARIOUS MEDICATIONS TO MANAGE MY
PAIN AND PTSD. WHEN I LEFT THE
MILITARY IN 2015, I SOUGHT
ALTERNATIVES TO THE
PHARMACEUTICALS THAT LEFT ME
FEELING DISCONNECTED AND NUMB. I
FOUND MORE EFFECTIVE AND
HOLISTIC APPROACHES THROUGH
RESEARCH AND SUPPORT FROM A
PHYSICIAN THAT HELPED ME TO
DISCOVER MEDICINAL CANNABIS
DOSAGE AND PRODUCTS. YET
FINANCIAL BARRIERS OFTEN MADE
ACCESS DIFFICULT WHEN I COULDN'T
AFFORD THE CANNABIS MEDICINE I
NEEDED, I THOUGHT MY ONLY OPTION
WAS TO RETURN TO
PHARMACEUTICALS. THAT'S WHEN I
DISCOVERED THE COMPASSIONATE
VETERANS COMMUNITY AND STARTED
RECEIVING COMPASSIONATE
DONATIONS THROUGH THEIR PROGRAM.
THIS COMMUNITY HAS SHOWN ME THE
POWER OF HAVING CHOICES IN
HEALTH CARE AND THE IMPORTANCE
OF ACCESSIBLE, DIGNIFIED CARE.
AB 2555 IS NOT JUST ABOUT
MAINTAINING ACCESS TO CANNABIS,
IT'S ABOUT ENSURING THAT
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES CONTINUE
TO RECEIVE ESSENTIAL HEALTH
CARE. THE EXPIRATION OF THE
CURRENT TAX EXEMPTIONS THREATENS
THE STABILITY AND CONTINUITY OF
THESE VITAL SERVICES. THIS BILL
IS ABOUT PROTECTING OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AND
UPHOLDING THE BARE MINIMUM
STANDARDS OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS.
IT ALIGNS WITH OUR STATE'S
INTENT TO PRIORITIZE HEALTH CARE
EQUITY AND SOCIAL JUSTICE BY
SUPPORTING AB 2555, YOU AFFIRM
YOUR COMMITMENT TO ENSURING THAT
ALL CALIFORNIANS, ESPECIALLY
THOSE MOST IN NEED, HAVE ACCESS
TO SAFE AND EFFECTIVE MEDICAL
CARE. YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB 2555
WILL PRESERVE CALIFORNIA'S
COMPASSIONATE CARE LEGACY AND
ENSURE OUR COMMUNITIES CAN
THRIVE. LET'S UPHOLD OUR STATE'S
VALUES OF COMPASSION AND HEALTH
CARE EQUITY. THANK YOU. I'M VERY
ANXIOUS. THANK YOU. YOU DID VERY
WELL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE. WE APPRECIATE IT.
NOW YOU CAN JUST, MR. MILLER.
THANK YOU. FLOOR IS YOURS,
HONORABLE CHAIR. ESTEEMED
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
RICHARD MILLER, ON BEHALF OF
AMERICANS FOR SAFE ACCESS AND
THE AMERICAN ALLIANCE FOR
MEDICAL CANNABIS, I COME TO YOU
TODAY AS A VOICE FOR THOSE
PATIENTS OFTEN UNHEARD OR UNABLE
TO BE HERE. OUR VETERANS ARE
SENIORS, AND THOSE PATIENTS
SUFFERING CHRONIC CONDITIONS AND
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
PATIENTS TO EXPRESS OUR
UNWAVERING SUPPORT ON AB 2555.
THIS BILL IS NOT JUST A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. IT IS A LIFELINE TO
SO MANY THAT STRUGGLE ON A DAILY
BASIS WITH CHRONIC, DISABLING
CONDITIONS THAT REQUIRE MEDICAL
CANNABIS TO ALLEVIATE THEIR
SUFFERING OR PHARMACEUTICALS
WON'T WORK OR COME WITH TWO
HEAVY SIDE EFFECTS BY ADDRESSING
THE SYSTEMIC INADEQUACIES IN OUR
TAX SYSTEM, AB 2555 PAVES THE
WAY FOR A MORE JUST AND
COMPASSIONATE SOCIETY. IT
ENSURES THAT OUR REVENUE
POLICIES REFLECT OUR VALUES OF
FAIRNESS AND EMPATHY. IT ALSO
PROVIDES ESSENTIAL SUPPORT TO
THOSE MEDICAL CANNABIS PATIENTS
MOST IN NEED FROM MY EXPERIENCE
WORKING IN PROVIDING
COMPASSIONATE MEDICINE TO
APPROXIMATELY 200 PLUS
COMPASSION PATIENTS AT A
THERAPEUTIC ALTERNATIVE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO, I DO AGREE WITH THE
COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS THAT THIS
IS A BUT FOR TAX BENEFIT, IT IS
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THESE PRODUCTS, WHICH COMPANIES
VOLUNTARILY DONATE AND WHICH ARE
RECEIVED BY ECONOMICALLY
VULNERABLE MEDICAL PATIENTS,
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN SOLD AND
THEREFORE WOULD NOT BE SUBJECT
TO THE SALES TAX IN THE FIRST
PLACE. THE PATIENTS WOULD NOT
AND COULD NOT AFFORD THESE
PRODUCTS. FAILURE TO IMPLEMENT
AB 2555 WOULD BE FORCED IN
PATIENTS TO EITHER GO WITHOUT OR
SEEKING UNTESTED, UNREGULATED
MARKETS, PUTTING THEIR HEALTH AT
FURTHER RISK. FOR MANY VETERANS,
THE BATTLE DOESN'T END WHEN THEY
RETURN HOME. THEY CARRY THE
PHYSICAL AND EMOTIONAL SCARS
THAT MAKE EVERYDAY LIFE STRUGGLE
. MEDICAL CANNABIS OFFERS THEM
THE CHANCE TO PEACE AND PAIN
RELIEF WITHOUT THE HEAVY
RELIANCE ON PRESCRIPTION
MEDICATIONS THAT OFTEN COME WITH
SEVERE SIDE EFFECTS. BY
EXTENDING THE SALES AND USE TAX
EXEMPTIONS ON DONATED MEDICAL
CANNABIS, WE ARE SHOWING OUR
VETERANS THAT WE HONOR THEIR
SACRIFICE AND ARE COMMITTED TO
THEIR WELL-BEING. OUR SENIORS,
MANY WHO HAVE LIVED ON FIXED
INCOMES FOR FACE CHRONIC
CONDITIONS AT TRADITIONAL
MEDICINES, CAN NO LONGER
ALLEVIATE EFFECTIVELY. THEY
DESERVE ACCESS TO SAFE,
EFFECTIVE AND AFFORDABLE MEDICAL
CANNABIS BY SUPPORTING AB 2555,
WE CAN EASE THE FINANCIAL
BURDENS AND PROVIDE THEM WITH
THE COMPASSIONATE CARE THEY SO
NEED AND DESERVE. LET'S NOT WRAP
UP. LET'S NOT FORGET THE
COUNTLESS INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES WHO ENDURE FINANCIAL
HARDSHIPS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB 2555.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE
GOING TO OPEN IT UP FOR THOSE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO DO ME TWOS
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM IN
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION,
PLEASE COME ON UP TO THE
MICROPHONE NAME AND AFFILIATION
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIRMAN. AND MEMBERS, AMY
O'GORMAN. JENKINS, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MISS JENKINS. GOOD
MORNING, GRACE COPLIN WITH
BROWNSTEIN ON BEHALF OF KIVA
CONFECTIONS IN SUPPORT OF THIS,
BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
NICOLE RUTLER, FOUNDER OF RE
COMPASS, IN SUPPORT. ALLISON
GLENN, COMPASSION PATIENT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ELLEN COMP,
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
NORML, REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA'S
CANNABIS CONSUMERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. KRISTIN
SPANGENBERG REPRESENTING THE
VETERANS FREE AND SAFE ACCESS
RANGER STATION IN 100% SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SHARON PENDARVIS, A
PATIENT OF A THERAPEUTIC
COMPASSION PROGRAM AND ALSO A
AZA MEMBER. ADVOCACY FOR LOW
INCOME PATIENTS AND I AM IN
FAVOR OF AB 255. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ZACHARY BOND, PURPLE HEART
VETERAN, IN COMPLETE SUPPORT OF
THIS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MARSHA BLOUNT FROM, SORRY,
I IN SUPPORT. SORRY. IT'S ALL
GOOD. THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
SHERRY MARTINEZ, COMPASSION
PATIENT IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ADEOLA. DEEP AS A PARENT,
PATIENT OF A CANCER SURVIVOR AND
AIDEN'S RELIEF I AM IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. ANGELA
KADARA PATIENT. I'VE HAD
OSTEOARTHRITIS ARTHRITIS SINCE
MY EARLY 30S. I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
ROYCE KOHLER. I'M A RETIRED
SOCIAL WORKER AND I'M IN
COMPLETE SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR. ANYBODY ELSE HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT? COME
ON UP TO THE MICROPHONE. ANDREA
RUDOLPH. COMPASSION. I 100,
AGREE WITH IT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE. APPRECIATE
IT. THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM? ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS LEGISLATION? SEEING NONE.
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SENATOR BRADFORD THEN
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR DONNELLY.
THANK YOU. I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR THIS COMMON SENSE
MEASURE, I HAVE HEARD FIRSTHAND
FROM NOT ONLY OUR VETERANS, BUT
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE SEEKING
MEDICAL ASSISTANCE TO BENEFITS
THAT ARE DERIVED FROM MEDICINAL
CANNABIS AND I'M HAPPY THAT WE
CAN ALLEVIATE THIS TAX, BECAUSE
I ALSO HAVE A MEASURE TO
ALLEVIATE THE TAX ON TAX JUST AT
THE REGULAR RETAILS AND MAKE IT
FAR MORE ACCESSIBLE AND
AFFORDABLE FOR INDIVIDUALS. SO
AND I'VE HEARD FIRSTHAND FROM
OUR VETERANS WHO HAVE STATED
THEY ARE FAR LESS SUICIDAL AND
ARE IN BETTER CARE BECAUSE OF
MEDICINAL CANNABIS VERSUS THE
PRESCRIBED DRUGS THAT DOCTORS
USUALLY DO PROVIDE TO THEM. SO
THANK YOU FOR THIS AND EXTENDING
THIS TAX. AND I'LL MAKE THE
MOTION WHEN THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU, SENATOR
BRADFORD. SENATOR DAWLEY, I'D
JUST LIKE TO LEND MY COMMENTS TO
THIS SENATOR FROM GARDENA. I'VE
HEARD FROM MANY VETERANS IN MY
DISTRICT AND NOT ONLY JUST
VETERANS, BUT PEOPLE WHO NEED
COMPASSION. AND THIS IS A TAX
THAT WE DO NOT NEED. SO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FORWARD. LOOK FORWARD TO VOTING
FOR IT. TERRIFIC. I ALSO JOINED
IN SUPPORTING THE BILL.
APPRECIATE SENATOR BRADFORD'S
LEADERSHIP IN THIS SPACE FOR A
LONG TIME WITH A. HE LIKES CBD.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THIS ON THE
UP AND UP, ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. DO YOU LIKE TO CLOSE,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. AYE,
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
SENATOR. WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM,
WE WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU TO ALL THE GUESTS WHO
CAME TO TESTIFY AS WELL. OKAY.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE. WE HAVE
ANOTHER AUTHOR IN THE ROOM, SO
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO FILE
ITEM THREE. ASSEMBLY BILL 2061
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON AND
THEN FILE ITEM FOUR, ASSEMBLY
BILL 3259 BY THE SAME AUTHOR.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. AND
YOU. WHICH BILL WOULD YOU LIKE
TO GO FIRST ON, I FILE ITEM
THREE 2061, PREPARED TO GO IN
ORDER. TERRIFIC. ALL RIGHT. AN
ORDER ORDER, ORDER IS GOOD.
SOMETIMES ALL RIGHT. PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MR. CHAIR,
SENATORS, I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB 2061, WHICH WILL ESTABLISH A
NEW EXEMPTION FROM THE STATE
PORTION OF THE SALES AND USE TAX
FOR THE PURCHASE OF ZERO
EMISSION FERRIES BY PUBLIC
TRANSIT AGENCIES, SUCH AS LONG
BEACH TRANSIT WAY DE VIDA AND
GOLDEN GATE FERRY THROUGH 2030.
THIS WILL REDUCE THE COST TO
DEPLOY ZERO EMISSION FERRIES AND
TO HELP THEM COMPLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD,
ALSO KNOWN AS CARB COMMERCIAL
HARBOR CRAFT REGULATIONS. CHC
THE CARB APPROVED AMENDMENTS TO
THE CHC REGULATIONS IN 2023, AND
IT WOULD REQUIRE PUBLIC TRANSIT
AGENCIES TO DEPLOY ZERO EMISSION
FERRIES BY 2026. NOW, WHEN
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC TRANSIT
FERRY OPERATORS FACE. FACED
EXCUSE ME, CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
TRANSIT FERRY OPERATORS FACE
IMPEDING TRANSIT OPERATIONS
FUNDING SHORTFALLS DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC'S IMPACT ON
PARTNERSHIPS. THIS BILL WOULD
PROVIDE CAPITAL OUTLAY, COST
SAVINGS, ALLOWING ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO BE MAINTAINED FOR
TRANSIT OPERATIONS, EXEMPTING
ZERO EMISSION FERRIES PURCHASED
BY PUBLIC AGENCIES FROM STATE
SALES AND USE TAX IS ESTIMATED
TO SAVE CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
TRANSIT FERRY OPERATORS MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS, AND IT WILL HELP US
REACH CALIFORNIA'S GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION GOALS. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS TERENCE
CANDLE, GOVERNMENT AND
REGULATORY AFFAIRS SPECIALIST
FOR SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA WATER
EMERGENCY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY, OR SF BAY FERRY.
GREAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
CANDLE. THE FLOOR IS YOURS. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES, GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR GLAZER AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I'M TERENCE CANDLE, THE
GOVERNMENT AND REGULATORY
AFFAIRS SPECIALIST FOR THE WATER
EMERGENCY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY. THE AGENCY THAT
OPERATES SAN FRANCISCO BAY
FERRY, SAN FRANCISCO BAY FERRY
IS A REGIONAL TRANSIT AGENCY
THAT IS TASKED WITH OPERATING
AND EXPANDING FERRY SERVICE ON
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AND WITH
COORDINATING WATER TRANSIT
RESPONSE TO REGIONAL
EMERGENCIES. WE CARRY OVER 3
MILLION PASSENGERS ANNUALLY ON
17 HIGH SPEED, PASSENGER ONLY
FERRY VESSELS. WE IS A
CO-SPONSOR OF AB 2006 ONE, WHICH
WOULD ESTABLISH A NEW PARTIAL
SALE AND USE TAX, WHICH WOULD,
PROVIDE AN EXEMPTION FOR ZERO
EMISSION FERRIES PURCHASED BY
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT AGENCIES.
THIS THIS EXEMPTION WOULD ASSIST
THE THREE TRANSIT AGENCIES IN
THE STATE THAT OPERATE A TOTAL
OF 28 FERRY VESSELS,
ACCELERATING OUR TRANSITION TO
ZERO EMISSION AND REDUCING THE
IMPACT COST OF COMPLYING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD'S COMMERCIAL HARBOR CRAFT,
OR CHC REGULATION. CARB'S RECENT
AMENDMENT TO THE CHC REGULATION
WENT INTO EFFECT ON JANUARY
FIRST, 2023. THIS REGULATION
REQUIRES A SUBSTANTIAL,
REDUCTION OF EMISSIONS BY THE
FERRY INDUSTRY ON AN ACCELERATED
TIMELINE, INCENTIVIZING
IMPLEMENTING NEW ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGY AND REQUIRING FERRIES
OPERATING ON ROUTES ON UNDER
THREE THREE MILES TO BE FULLY
ZERO EMISSION BY JANUARY 1ST,
2026. TRANSITIONING TO ZERO
EMISSION REQUIRES A SIGNIFICANT
CAPITAL INVESTMENT, AND THIS IS
AT A TIME WHEN FERRY OPERATORS
ARE WORKING TO RECOVER FROM THE
DEVASTATING FINANCIAL IMPACTS OF
THE PANDEMIC. IN FACT, WIDA HAS
ESTIMATED THAT IT WOULD COST 500
TO $700 MILLION TO UPGRADE OUR
ELECTRICAL CAPACITY AT FERRY
TERMINALS, REPLACE OLD DIESEL
VESSELS WITH NEW ZERO EMISSION
VESSELS AND CONVERT NEWER DIESEL
VESSELS TO ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGY. IS WORKING HARD TO
SECURE COMPETITIVE GRANT FUNDING
, ADVOCATING FOR NEW AND
EXPANDED GRANT FUNDING SOURCES
AND MEANS OF IMPLEMENTATION COST
REDUCTION, INCLUDING SEEKING
THIS TAX EXEMPTION IN 2019 AND
2022. SIMILAR BILLS AB 784 AND
AB 2622 WERE PASSED TO PROVIDE
BUS OPERATORS WITH THIS SAME
SALES TAX EXEMPTION FOR
PURCHASING ZERO EMISSION BUSSES.
WITH THIS BILL, IS PROPOSING
THAT WE PROVIDE THAT SAME
BENEFIT TO PUBLIC TRANSIT FERRY
OPERATORS. THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING THE PROPOSAL AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO WANTS TO INDICATE THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THIS LEGISLATION?
COME ON UP TO THE MICROPHONE.
HI. GRACE COPLIN, ON BEHALF OF
THE BAY AREA COUNCIL, PROUD TO
CO-SPONSOR THIS MEASURE. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, BEN TRIFFO
WITH THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
MORNING, ERIC LARA ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES AND SUPPORT. GREAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL MOVE TO OPPOSITION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE COME
FORWARD. SEEING NONE, WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TODAY. IT'S A GOOD
BILL, FOR THE REASONS THAT YOU
HAVE STATED AND YOUR WITNESSES
STATED, IS THERE ANYTHING YOU'D
LIKE TO SAY IN YOUR CLOTHES?
JUST, APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THIS IS JUST THE STATE PORTION
AND THESE ARE INVESTMENTS THAT
WE MAKE WHEN WE DO RECEIVE THOSE
FUNDS. THESE ARE THE TYPE OF
INVESTMENTS WE MAKE. SO THIS IS
JUST ASKING PARITY BETWEEN OUR
BUSSES AND OUR FERRIES THAT DO
THE SAME THING, TRANSPORT PEOPLE
TO THEIR JOBS, TO THEIR
RECREATION, TO ALL, TO ALL THE
THINGS THAT THEY NEED TO DO TO
HAVE A GOOD QUALITY OF LIFE. AND
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
INVEST IN. AND SO WITH THAT,
WHEN THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE SENATORS
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MA'AM, AND WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM, WE'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO DO JUST THAT. SO WITH THAT,
WE'LL CLOSE THE HEARING ON THIS
BILL AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO, FILE
ITEM FOUR. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
3259. AND YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU. MY
WITNESSES ARE COMING UP. GREAT.
MR. CHAIR, SENATORS, I'M PLEASED
TO PRESENT AB 3259. THIS IS A
DISTRICT BILL THAT WOULD PROVIDE
NEEDED FLEXIBILITY FOR RESIDENTS
IN SOLANO COUNTY TO VOTE ON
LOCAL REVENUE MEASURES TO
PROTECT ESSENTIAL SERVICES AND
IMPROVE CRITICAL TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE. SPECIFICALLY,
THIS BILL WOULD RAISE THE
STATUTORY TRANSACTION AND USE
TAX LIMIT ABOVE THE 2% CAP TO
ALLOW CITIES WITHIN SOLANO
COUNTY TO VOTE ON MEASURES THAT
RAISE LOCAL REVENUE AT A RATE
NOT TO EXCEED 0.5, WITH A SUNSET
IN 2029 CURRENTLY A CITIZEN
INITIATIVE PUT ON THE BALLOT BY
RESIDENTS IN THE CITY OF BENICIA
WOULD, IF APPROVED BY VOTERS,
PUT THE CITY ABOVE THE CAP.
EARLIER THIS YEAR, VOTERS IN THE
CITY OF BENICIA OVERWHELMINGLY
APPROVED A THREE QUARTER CENT
GENERAL PURPOSE SALES TAX
INCREASE TO SUPPORT PUBLIC
SAFETY AND ESSENTIAL SERVICES.
AT THE SAME TIME, RESIDENTS IN
BENICIA HAD FORMED A COALITION
TO DRAFT THE CITIZEN INITIATIVE
FOR THE NOVEMBER BALLOT FOR THE
SPECIFIC PURPOSE OF INCREASING
REVENUE TO IMPROVE ROAD
CONDITIONS. HOWEVER, WITH THE
RECENT SALES TAX INITIATIVE
APPROVED BY THE VOTERS, IF THE
NOVEMBER CITIZEN BALLOT
INITIATIVE WERE TO PASS, IT
WOULD THEN PUT THE CITY ABOVE
THE 2% COUNTY CAP. THIS BILL
DOES NOT RAISE OR ENACT ANY NEW
TAXES. IT SIMPLY EMPOWERS VOTERS
WITHIN SOLANO COUNTY BY ALLOWING
THEM TO DECIDE WHETHER TO
APPROVE LOCAL REVENUE MEASURES
THAT WOULD EXCEED THE 2% CAP
UNTIL 2029. WITH ME TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ARE
MEMBERS FROM THE CITY OF
BENICIA. WE HAVE MAYOR YOUNG AND
CITY MANAGER MARIO TERRIFIC,
USUALLY THE MAYOR GOES FIRST. SO
ALL RIGHT, THAT WOULD BE ME.
WELCOME. THANK YOU, SIR, AND I
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLYWOMAN
WILSON FOR SPONSORING THIS BILL,
NOT ONLY ON OUR BEHALF, BUT FOR
OTHER CITIES IN SOLANO COUNTY AS
WELL. AND AS SHE STATED, THE
CITY OF BENICIA, LIKE A LOT OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS, IS FACING
SOME SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES. WE WERE SUCCESSFUL
IN MARCH GETTING A SALES TAX
MEASURE APPROVED BY THE VOTERS,
CONCURRENTLY, THERE WAS A
CITIZEN EFFORT TO, PUT ON THE
BALLOT A MEASURE, A SPECIAL TAX
JUST FOR ROAD IMPROVEMENTS. AND
IT RECEIVED THE MUCH MORE THAN
THE NECESSARY NUMBER OF
SIGNATURES. SO THERE IS AN
EXPECTATION ON THE PART OF THE
CITIZENS THAT THERE BE ABLE TO
VOTE ON IMPROVING THEIR ROADS.
AND THIS CAN ONLY HAPPEN IF THIS
BILL GOES FORWARD AND PROVIDES
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY. IT'S AN
EXERCISE IN SELF-GOVERNMENT AND
WILLING TO TAX YOURSELF TO
IMPROVE YOUR OWN LOCAL
CONDITIONS AND WE WOULD
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT THE
COMMITTEE WOULD SUPPORT IT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. CITY
MANAGER, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU, MAYOR, AND
THANK YOU, ASSEMBLYWOMAN. JUST
TO CONCLUDE AND PROVIDE CONTEXT
FOR THE COMMITTEE IN BENESCH'S
CASE, OUR ROADS HAVE A PAVEMENT
CONDITION INDEX OF 56. AND FOR
CONTEXT, A PAVEMENT CONDITION
INDEX OF 70 IS GOOD OR FAIR. OUR
CONDITION WILL CONTINUE TO
WORSEN AND WORSEN AND WORSEN
UNLESS WE HAVE LOCAL INVESTMENT
TO IMPROVE THOSE ROADS. AND SO
THE MATTER BEFORE YOU TODAY IS
OUR ABILITY TO EMPLOY SELF-HELP
TO ALLOW OUR OWN RESIDENTS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAX THEMSELVES TO
FIX OUR ROADS. WITHOUT THAT
ADDITIONAL REVENUE, THE CITY OF
BENICIA DOES NOT HAVE THE
WHEREWITHAL TO MAKE THE PROPER
INVESTMENT TO IMPROVE OUR ROADS.
IF WE HAVE THIS NOT ONLY WILL
BENICIA BE ABLE TO BE SUCCESSFUL
IN IMPROVING OUR INFRASTRUCTURE,
SO TOO WILL OTHER COMMUNITIES IN
SOLANO COUNTY. IN FACT, LATER
TODAY I'M MEETING WITH THE OTHER
CITY MANAGERS IN SOLANO COUNTY,
WHERE THEY'RE ALREADY LOOKING
AHEAD TO TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THIS LEGISLATION FOR ACTION IN
2026. SO IT'S NOT JUST THE CITY
OF BENICIA THAT YOU'RE AIDING.
YOU'RE AIDING OTHER COMMUNITIES.
AND I WILL CONCLUDE AGAIN BY
SAYING THIS IS A SELF HELP
INITIATIVE. AND SO WHEN THE TIME
IS APPROPRIATE, WE ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON THIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR BOTH OF YOU. WE'RE GOING TO
OPEN IT UP FOR THOSE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO WANT TO ALSO
INDICATE THEIR SUPPORT WITH
THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION,
PLEASE COME TO THE MIC. CLIFTON
WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE SOLANO
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SIR. ANYONE ELSE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM IN SUPPORT? ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION.
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO WANTS TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION? PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS, ASSEMBLY MEMBER, I DID
COME FROM A LOCAL CITY TEN YEARS
AND I KNOW THE SELF-HELP PLEA IS
ONE THAT I CERTAINLY, ADVANCED
IN MY SERVICE, PRINCIPALLY FOR
OUR ROAD CONDITIONS. AND, ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE I ALWAYS
REGRETTED WHEN I WAS ON THE
COUNCIL WAS, WAS THAT THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION WOULD PUT OUT THEIR
LIST OF 100, LIKE, 101 CITIES
AND JURISDICTIONS IN THE BAY
AREA AND WHERE YOU RANKED
BECAUSE FOR MANY YEARS MY TOWN
WAS AT THE BOTTOM AT THE BOTTOM.
YEAH. AND, IT WAS ONLY THROUGH
OUR, LEADERSHIP OF OUR COMMUNITY
AND THE GOOD SUPPORT OF OUR
CITIZENRY THAT WE'RE NOW AT THE
TOP. AND THAT'S, THAT TOOK A
LONG TIME. AND IT TOOK IT TOOK
MONEY TO DO IT. BUT THESE TYPES
OF MEASURES THAT YOU'RE
ADVANCING ARE WHAT COMMUNITIES
NEED AS TOOLS. IT'S STILL THEIR
CHOICE. AND IT'S FOR THAT REASON
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL.
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO SAY IN
CLOSING, THANK YOU. I JUST
REMIND THE COMMITTEE IN
PARTICULAR, THIS IS FOR OUR
WHOLE COUNTY. BUT THE CITY OF
BENICIA WAS ONCE OUR STATE
CAPITAL, SO THAT TELLS YOU HOW
OLD IT IS AND HOW OLD SOME OF
THOSE ROADS ARE. AND SO, SO GLAD
THAT THE CITIZENS HAVE DECIDED
UPON THEMSELVES TO, CHIP IN. SO
TO SPEAK, AND TO SAY, TO ASK TO
CHIP IN SO THAT THEY CAN GET IT
DONE AND HAPPY TO FACILITATE
THAT FOR THEM. SO I RESPECTFULLY
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME, ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. WOULD YOU SAY THAT
VENETIA IS LIKE YOUR YOUR
FAVORITE CITY OR YOU'RE TRYING
TO GET ME IN TROUBLE? OH MY GOSH
, IT IT IS ONE OF MY FAVORITE
CITIES OF THE EIGHT CITIES THAT
I REPRESENT. THAT'S WHY YOU'RE
AN OUTSTANDING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND WE APPRECIATE YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU FOR IT IS MY FAVORITE
CAPITAL OF CALIFORNIA. MARTINEZ.
YOU DON'T HAVE MARTINEZ. YOU'RE.
I DO NOT, I DO NOT. ALL RIGHT.
OKAY. TERRIFIC THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION. WE'LL TAKE UP A
MOTION WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU ALL. THANKS FOR BEING
HERE. MR. CARILLO IS HERE.
TERRIFIC. OKAY, WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM SEVEN.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2443 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE HERE TODAY
. YEAH. ANOTHER ONE. WOW. I'M
GOING LETTER FOR STAFF TO
PRESENT THE AWARD. GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
SENATORS, THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT A SIMILAR BILL TO
THE PREVIOUS ONE. THIS IS A VERY
SIMPLE BILL THAT WILL ALLOW
THREE CITIES IN MY DISTRICT THE
CITIES OF VICTORVILLE, PALMDALE
AND LANCASTER, ALL MY FAVORITE
CITIES TO RAISE CRITICALLY
NEEDED RESOURCES AT A LOCAL
LEVEL. ONE OF THE PRIMARY THINGS
THAT COMMUNITIES IN MY DISTRICT
HAVE IN COMMON IS THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN LEFT BEHIND. WHEN THE
PEOPLE OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
THINK ABOUT THIS, THEY'RE NOT
THINKING ABOUT THE CITY OF
PALMDALE AND LANCASTER. AND WHEN
THE PEOPLE THINK OF SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY, THEY'RE NOT
THINKING ABOUT ADELANTO AND
VICTORVILLE. FOR EXAMPLE,
MEASURE H IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
FUNDS HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY, BUT IT
ONLY RETURNS $0.15 FOR EVERY
DOLLAR TO PALMDALE. MY COMMUNITY
IS IN THE HIGH DESERT, ARE
CONSISTENTLY FORGETTING ABOUT
AND LEFT OUT OF CRITICAL
RESOURCES AT BOTH THE STATE AND
THE COUNTY LEVEL. THIS MEASURE
SIMPLY ALLOWS THEM TO DO IT
THEMSELVES, TO RAISE FUNDS
LOCALLY, TO MEET THE LOCAL NEEDS
OF THIS CITY. I DO NOT HAVE ANY
PRIMARY WITNESSES WITH ME TODAY,
MISTER CHAIR, BUT I'LL BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
TERRIFIC. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. ANYONE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE THEIR SUPPORT FOR THIS
LEGISLATION? COME ON FORWARD.
MR. CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, PAUL GONSALVES, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF PALMDALE
AND VICTORVILLE, WE LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. HE DID
A GREAT JOB OF EXPLAINING THE
NEED. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IF NEED BE. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
ANYBODY ELSE HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM IN SUPPORT? WE'LL GO TO
OPPOSITION. ANYONE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM IN OPPOSITION. COME
ON. FORWARD SEEING NONE, WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
TERRIFIC ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO, CONSISTENT WITH MY VIEW
OF THESE MATTERS, I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL. APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING IT FORWARD. ON
BEHALF OF YOUR FAVORITE CITIES.
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO SAY? IN
CLOSING, I ALSO WANT TO ADD TO
THE RECORD THAT THE CITY OF
ATLANTA AND THE CITY OF
HILLSBOROUGH, ALSO MY FAVORITE
CITIES IN THE SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY, A GOOD DIPLOMAT,
TERRIFIC AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM, WE'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. THANK YOU,
SIR. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. WE.
THIS IS, ONLY HAPPENED ONCE IN
MY CHAIRMANSHIP. HAVE I HAD A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE STAFF OF
A MEMBER TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF A
BILL, AND NOW WE HAVE IT
HAPPENING TWICE IN A SINGLE
HEARING, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NEXT TO, FILE ITEM SIX. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2353 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD AND PRESENTING ON
HIS BEHALF IS SAVERIO RIZZO.
LEMUS AM I PRONOUNCING THAT
RIGHT? YES, SIR. HAVE YOU EVER
PRESENTED A BILL BEFORE? NO,
SIR. FIRST TIME. OKAY. I'M SURE
YOU'LL DO GREAT. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. I WOULDN'T READ THOSE
REMARKS. WHO PREPARED THEM FOR
YOU? I WOULD AD LIB. OKAY THANK
YOU SIR. I'LL TRY IT ON TV
FOREVER, WELL, FIRST OF ALL,
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU
FOR GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB 2553 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHRIS WARD, WHO
IS UNFORTUNATELY UNABLE TO BE
HERE AS HE IS CURRENTLY CHAIRING
THE ASSEMBLY, HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE,
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
AND, ACCEPT ALL OF THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS, AB 2353 WOULD ENSURE
THAT NONPROFIT, AFFORDABLE
RENTAL HOUSING DEVELOPERS CAN
ACCESS THE EXISTING WELFARE
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION WITHOUT
FLOATING UNNECESSARY TAX
PAYMENTS WHILE THEIR APPLICATION
IS UNDER REVIEW. CURRENTLY
AFFORDABLE RENTAL HOUSING
DEVELOPERS MUST PAY PROPERTY
TAXES UP FRONT AND SEEK
REIMBURSEMENT AFTER THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION, AND THE COUNTY
ASSESSOR HAS HAVE APPROVED A
DEVELOPER'S EXEMPTION AS A
RESULT, AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS FLOAT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
UNNECESSARY TAX PAYMENTS FOR AS
LONG AS THREE YEARS, ONLY TO GET
THE MONEY BACK, ALBEIT WITHOUT
THE INTEREST INCURRED. ONCE
THEIR APPLICATION IS APPROVED.
AB 2353 WOULD REDUCE THE COST OF
DEVELOPING AFFORDABLE HOUSING BY
ALLOWING NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS TO WITHHOLD
RELEVANT TAX PAYMENTS WITHOUT
PENALTY, WHILE THEIR WELFARE
EXEMPTION APPLICATIONS ARE UNDER
REVIEW. IF THE PROPERTY HAS
RECEIVED A RESERVATION OF TAX
CREDITS FROM TCAC OR AN AWARD
FROM OF FUNDS FROM HCD, AND IS
ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE THAT
CONSTRUCTION HAS BEGUN, FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, I HAVE
MARK STIVERS, DIRECTOR OF
ADVOCACY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP. TERRIFIC.
YOU DID THAT VERY WELL. THANK
YOU. LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
TESTIMONY OF YOUR WITNESS.
MORNING. CHAIR AND MEMBERS, MARK
STIVERS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP. WE ARE
ALWAYS LOOKING FOR WAYS TO
REDUCE THE COST OF DEVELOPING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND STRETCH
OUR STATE DOLLARS FURTHER, ONE
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE HAVE HERE IS
TO IS HOW WE ADMINISTER THE
WELFARE EXEMPTION, PROPERTY TAX
EXEMPTION. AND, MR. RIZZO HAS
DESCRIBED THE BILL QUITE WELL,
BUT I JUST WANT TO PUT A LITTLE
BIT OF DATA TO THIS AND THAT.
THERE'S ABOUT 163 AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS THAT THE
STATE FUNDS PER YEAR, ASSUMING
THAT IT TAKES TWO YEARS TO GET
THE WELFARE EXEMPTION FOR EACH
OF THOSE DEVELOPMENTS AND THAT
THE SAVINGS TO EACH DEVELOPMENT
IS ABOUT 200,000 A YEAR, THAT
MEANS WE HAVE $64 MILLION IN
PRIVATE CAPITAL FROM AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS. THAT'S TIED
UP JUST WAITING FOR THESE
REFUNDS TO BE, THE APPLICATIONS
TO BE PROCESSED AND THE REFUNDS
TO BE ADMINISTERED SO THAT MONEY
CAN BE PUT TO BUILDING
ADDITIONAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND SO WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
TERRIFIC. ANYBODY ELSE HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WANT TO
INDICATE SUPPORT? PLEASE COME TO
THE MICROPHONE. CLIFTON WILSON,
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, GRACE
COPELAND ON BEHALF OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
ANYONE ELSE IN THE HEARING ROOM
ON SUPPORT? SEEING NONE. WE'LL
GO TO OPPOSITION. ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE?
PLEASE COME FORWARD SEEING NONE.
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE. THANK YOU
FOR PRESENTING THE BILL ON
BEHALF OF YOUR ASSEMBLY. MEMBER
WARD. I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL AND WE HAVE A QUORUM. WE'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION AT THAT TIME.
IS THERE ANYTHING I WANT TO SAY
IN CLOSING, NO, SIR. THANK YOU.
I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. YOU DIDN'T HAVE ANY
WRITTEN CLOSING REMARKS
PREPARED, THOSE THOSE WERE MY
STAFFERS. THEY'RE NOT ALWAYS ON
TOP OF THINGS. THERE SO THANK
YOU FOR PRESENTING. WE
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU GUYS.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE LOOKING
FOR A SINGLE AUTHOR. I BELIEVE,
AND THAT'S ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL. IS HE CHAIRING, BUDGET
IS ASSEMBLY BUDGET GOING? NO,
NO, THIS IS IN HIS OFFICE. OKAY
WE COULD ASK HIM TO PLEASE COME
ON DOWN AND LET ME ASK THE
REMAINING MEMBERS OF OUR REVENUE
AND TAXATION COMMITTEE TO PLEASE
COME TO THE HEARING ROOM SO WE
CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND
DISPENSE WITH OUR BUSINESS. WITH
THAT, WE'LL TAKE A SHORT RECESS.
WE, I BELIEVE, HAVE A
QUORUM NOW. SO IF THE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE, THE ATTENDANCE
SENATORS. GLASER. GLASER
PRESENT. DOLLY. DOLLY. PRESENT.
ASHBY BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
PRESENT. DODD PRESENT. DODD.
PRESENT. PADILLA SKINNER. YOU
HAVE A QUORUM. OKAY. WE HAVE A
QUORUM PRESENT. SO MEMBERS, WE
HAVE DEALT WITH, ALL THE BILLS
ON OUR AGENDA, EXCEPT FOR ONE.
WE HAVE NO MOTIONS. SO I WOULD
ASK YOUR, ATTENTION TO SEE IF WE
HAVE MOTIONS TO ADVANCE THESE
MATTERS. FIRST, LET'S BEGIN WITH
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM.
SENATOR DODD HAS MOVED THE
CONSENT CALENDAR, AND THAT'S,
ASSEMBLY BILL 1879, FILE ITEM
NINE, ASSEMBLY BILL 2564 AND
FILE ITEM 11, ASSEMBLY BILL
2897. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MOTION IS ADOPTED. CONSENT
CALENDAR. SENATORS GLASER.
GLASER I. DOLLY. DOLLY I ASHBY.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I DODD. DODD
I. PADILLA SKINNER. 4 TO 0. I'LL
PUT THAT ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. WE'LL MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO. THIS WAS PULLED
OFF OF CONSENT. THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL 1973. LOOKING FOR A MOTION.
SO MOVED. I MOVED BY SENATOR
DOLLY, SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS. GLASER. GLASER I.
DOLLY. DOLLY, I ASHBY. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. I DODD. DODD I PADILLA
. SKINNER. 4 TO 0. I'LL LEAVE
THAT ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
2061 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON.
MOVE, SENATOR DODD'S MOVED THE
BILL. THIS IS DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS.
GLASER. GLASER I. DOLLY. DOLLY,
I. ASHBY. BRADFORD. BRADFORD. I
DODD. DODD I. PADILLA. SKINNER 4
TO 0. I'LL LEAVE THAT ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. WE'LL MOVE
NEXT TO FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 3259 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON. LOOKING
FOR A MOTION, SENATOR BRADFORD
MOVES THE BILL. THIS IS A DUE
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS. GLASER. GLASER. I
DOLLY. DOLLY. NØ. ASHBY
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I DODD. DODD
I. PADILLA. SKINNER. 3 TO 1.
LEAVE THAT ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. MOVING TO NEXT BILL.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE, THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2238 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW. SENATOR BRADFORD
MOVES THE BILL. THIS IS DO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR
GLASER. NOT VOTING. DOLLY ASHBY.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I DODD DODD I
PADILLA. SKINNER. 2 TO 0. LEAVE
THAT ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
MOVING NEXT TO FILE ITEM SIX.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2353 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD. LOOKING FOR A
MOTION. SENATOR DOLLY MOVED THE
BILL. HE ACCEPTED THE HIS
REPRESENTATIVE ACCEPTED THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE IN THE
COMMITTEE. ANALYSIS. DO PASS IS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR GLASER. GLASER I DOLLY.
DOLLY I ASHBY. BRADFORD BRADFORD
I DODD DODD. I PADILLA. SKINNER.
4 TO 0. THAT ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. MOVING NEXT TO FILE.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN. ASSEMBLY BILL
2443 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO.
THIS WOULD BE A DO PASS TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. IS THERE A MOTION?
MOVED BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS. GLASER. GLASER. I
DOLLY. NO. DOLLY. NO ASHBY.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. I DODD DODD
I PADILLA. SKINNER. 3 TO 1.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT IS NEXT UP. IT'S ASSEMBLY
BILL 2555 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA. MOVE THE BILL BY
SENATOR DOLLY. THIS WOULD BE DO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS GLASER. GLASER I.
DOLLY. DOLLY I ASHBY. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I DODD DODD I PADILLA.
SKINNER. 4 TO 0. THAT ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. WE'LL MOVE
NEXT TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2854 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ERWIN. IT'S A Dð
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. IS THERE
A MOTION? MOVE SENATOR BRADFORD
MOVES THE BILL. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE BILL. THE ROLL.
SENATORS. GLASER. GLASER I
DOLLY. DOLLY, I ASHBY. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. I DODD DODD I PADILLA.
SKINNER. 4 TO 0. WE THAT ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS, FINALLY
WE'LL GO TO FILE ITEM NUMBER 12.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 3134 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHINN, MOTION BY
SENATOR DOLLY. THIS IS Dð PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
GLASER. GLASER I DOLLY. DOLLY I
ASHBY. BRADFORD BRADFORD I DODD
DODD. I PADILLA. SKINNER. 4 TO
0. OKAY, WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON
CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. THAT
LEAVES US WITH ONE BILL
REMAINING. WE'LL WAIT FOR THE
AUTHOR TO ARRIVE. I KNOW HE'S A
VERY IMPORTANT BILL, AND SO
WE'LL WE'LL GO ON RECESS FOR
JUST A MOMENT. AGAIN
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON REVENUE
TAX WILL COME BACK TO ORDER. I'M
GOING TO, TURN THE GAVEL OVER TO
THE VICE CHAIR. SENATOR DOLLY.
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR OR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL, SENATOR GLASER
IS GOING TO PRESENT AB 3160. WHO
WERE THE WITNESSES? DID YOU GUYS
WITNESS? Ó. DANNY. GOOD YOU MAY
PROCEED, SENATOR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, VICE CHAIR. IS THIS
MICROPHONE WORKING? NO, IT'S NOW
WORKING. ALL RIGHT. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL, THIS
BILL SUPPORTS ONE OF THE MOST
CRITICAL STATE FUNDING SOURCES
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THE
STATE LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDIT. BY PLANNING FOR THE LONG
TERM CERTAINTY OF THE CREDIT, WE
CAN ENSURE DEVELOPERS CAN DEPEND
ON THIS CRITICAL FUNDING SOURCE
WHEN PLANNING FOR FUTURE HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION. THE STATE'S LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT WILL
ALLOW FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF
OVER 6000 UNITS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING EACH YEAR AND GENERATE
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL, LOCAL AND
PRIVATE FUNDING AT RATIOS AS
GREAT AS 5 TO 1. MAKING THIS
CHANGE AN EXTREMELY PRUDENT AND
EFFECTIVE USE OF THE STATE'S
FINANCIAL RESOURCES. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THE BILL IS
THE ESTEEMED DANNY CURTIN FROM
THE CARPENTERS, AND I'M SORRY, I
DON'T KNOW YOUR NAME. WILL
INTRODUCE MYSELF. MARK STIVERS,
CALIFORNIA HOUSING. OH RIGHT.
YOU TESTIFIED EARLIER. THAT'S
RIGHT. VERY WELL. ALL RIGHT.
WITH THAT RESPECT, ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER, GABRIEL, I
RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. CURTIN I'M GOING TO
FOLLOW. I'M GLAD YOU'RE
DEFERRING TO HIM. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. I'LL GET SOMEBODY WHO
KNOWS WHAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT. OKAY. BUT AGAIN, MARK
STIVERS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP, THE STATE
HAS FUNDED THESE CREDITS FOR THE
LAST FOUR YEARS. IT'S ALSO BEING
FUNDED IN THIS BUDGET THAT WILL
BE VOTED ON TONIGHT. IN THOSE
FOUR YEARS, THESE CREDITS HAVE
FUNDED OVER 25,000 NEW
AFFORDABLE HOMES FOR FAMILIES OF
VERY LOW AND EXTREMELY LOW
INCOMES. IT'S LEVERAGED $5.3
BILLION IN ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
RESOURCES THAT WE OTHERWISE
WOULD HAVE LEFT ON THE TABLE.
AND SO WE DO THINK THIS IS A
VERY SMART INVESTMENT THAT WILL
ALSO CREATE CERTAINTY FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY GOING
FORWARD. THE FIVE YEARS IS
SIMILAR TO WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS DONE FOR THE FILM, TAX
CREDIT AND OTHER TYPES OF TAX
CREDITS. AND THEN LASTLY, A
REPORT CAME OUT RECENTLY THAT WE
HAVE 46,000 AFFORDABLE HOMES
THAT ARE PERMITTED BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THEY ARE READY TO
GO TO CONSTRUCTION. THEY JUST
NEED THAT LAST STATE FINANCING
PIECE, THIS, THIS, THIS STATE
TAX CREDIT WILL BE THAT FUNDING
SOURCE FOR A LOT OF THOSE
DEVELOPMENTS. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND I TURN IT OVER TO MR.
CURTIN. SO NOT TO BELABOR IT TOO
MUCH, BUT THE HOUSING CRISIS IS
THE MOST DESTABILIZING CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR ECONOMIC,
SOCIALLY AND POLITICALLY. AS WE
GET DEEPER AND DEEPER INTO THIS,
THE PERMANENCY OF THIS FOR THE 5
OR 6 YEARS, I BELIEVE IT'S SIX
YEARS IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL.
AND ALL I CAN SAY IS WE NEED TO
DO THIS MORE THAN ALMOST
ANYTHING ELSE WE CAN DO AND
APPRECIATE YOUR VOTES. ALL
RIGHT. WE THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WANTS TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
PLEASE COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE. GRACE COPELAND, ON
BEHALF OF HOUSING CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MARINA
ESPINOSA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM IN
SUPPORT, ALSO REGISTERING
SUPPORT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION. TERRIFIC.
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE HEARING
ROOM? OKAY, WE'LL GO TO
OPPOSITION. ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL? PLEASE
COME FORWARD SEEING NONE. WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL,
WE WELCOME YOU TO THE COMMITTEE.
I KNOW YOU'VE GOT A LOT OF
THINGS GOING ON HERE IN THE
BUILDING, BUT THANK YOU. AND WE
WANT TO GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ADD ANYTHING YOU WISH, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR AND MY
VERY, VERY SINCERE APOLOGIES. I
KNOW HOW BUSY EVERYBODY IS THIS
TIME OF YEAR, AND I'M SO SORRY
ABOUT THE DELAY. I THINK THE
WITNESS HAS SAID IT. GREAT. THIS
IS A REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE, A
GREAT WAY FOR US TO LEVERAGE A
LOT OF OTHER FUNDING TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE. AND SO WITH THAT, I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE. TERRIFIC. ALL RIGHT,
SENATOR DALLI HAS MADE THE
MOTION. THIS IS DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS.
GLASER. GLASER. AYE, DOLLY.
DOLLY. AYE. ASHBY. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. DODD. AYE. DODD.
AYE PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE.
SKINNER. FIVE ZERO. TERRIFIC.
THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS. WE'LL
HOLD ON. CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES WHO
HAVE ALREADY VOTED. WE'RE GOING
TO OPEN UP THE ROLL FOR THOSE
WHO WERE NOT ABLE TO VOTE
EARLIER, WE WANT TO INVITE THE
ABSENT MEMBERS OF OUR COMMITTEE
TO COME TO THE HEARING ROOM SO
THAT WE CAN FINISH OUR BUSINESS,
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE JUST ANOTHER
PAUSE AS WE WAIT FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT. THE COMMITTEE ON
REVENUE TAX WILL BE BACK TO
ORDER. WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND OPEN THE ROLL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THIS
IS FILE ITEM ONE. FILE ITEM
NINE, AND FILE ITEM 11. FILE
ITEM TWO WAS PULLED OFF OF
CONSENT. SO ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR, SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS. CURRENT VOTE IS
4 TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS
ASHBY, PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE.
SKINNER. SKINNER. I'M 6 TO 0.
PUT THAT ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. MOVING NEXT TO FILE
ITEM TWO, AB 1973. SECRETARY,
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATE. CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0.
SENATORS ASHBY, PADILLA.
PADILLA. AYE. SKINNER 5 TO 0.
PUT THAT ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. NEXT UP, FILE ITEM
THREE AB 2061, PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL. MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0 WITH
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATORS ASHBY, PADILLA.
PADILLA. AYE. SKINNER SKINNER.
AYE. 6 TO 0. THEN ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. FILE ITEM FOUR
AB 3259. PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR WITH CHAIR VOTING AYE.
VICE CHAIR VOTING NO. CURRENT
VOTE IS 3 TO 1. SENATORS ASHBY.
PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE. 5 TO 1. HOLD THAT
ON. PUT THAT ON. CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. FILE ITEM FIVE AB 2238.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
2 TO 0. CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR.
NOT VOTING. SENATOR YES. WE
DIDN'T CALL THAT ONE EARLIER.
THIS ONE SECOND.
OKAY. SO WE'RE. YEAH.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE BACK AT FILE
ITEM FIVE. WE'RE GOING TO OPEN
THE ROLL AB 2238. PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
2 TO 0. CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR.
NOT VOTING. SENATORS. ASHBY.
PADILLA SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE. 3
TO 0. PUT THAT ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. WE'LL MOVE NEXT
TO FILE ITEM SIX. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2253. PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL. MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED, TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
4 TO 0, WITH CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR ASHBY
PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE. SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE 6 TO 0. WE'LL PUT
THAT ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM SEVEN 2443 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARRILLO, PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL. MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE.
SENATE, CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 1
WITH CHAIR VOTING AYE. VICE
CHAIR VOTING NO. SENATORS ASHBY.
PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE. SKINNER
SKINNER. AYE. 5 TO 1. WE'LL PUT
THAT ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM EIGHT AB 2005 55 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
4 TO 0 WITH CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATOR ASHBY
PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE. SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE. 6 TO 0. THAT ON
CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS, FILE
ITEM TEN AB 2854 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN, PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL. MOTION IS TO PASS THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 420 WITH CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR ASHBY. PADILLA. PADILLA.
AYE SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE. 6 TO
0. THAT ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. FILE ITEM 12 AB 3134 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN. PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL. MOTION IS TO PASS
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0 WITH
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR ASHBY. PADILLA. PADILLA
AYE. SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE. 6 TO
0. AYE FINALLY, FILE ITEM 13,
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 3001 60 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. GABRIEL. PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL. MOTION IS TO
PASS. SO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS 5
TO 0 WITH CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATOR ASHBY.
SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE 6 TO 0.
ALL RIGHT. WE'LL TAKE ANOTHER
RECESS.
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON REV AND
TAX WILL COME BACK TO ORDER.
THANKS, EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PATIENCE. TODAY WE GOT THIS
SPECIAL GAVEL AND I'M GOING TO
HAND OVER TO OUR ESTEEMED MEMBER
, SENATOR SKINNER, TO KIND OF
CLOSE US OUT TODAY. SO THIS IS
THE FORMAL PASSING. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR SKINNER. SO,
SENATE COMMITTEE ON RUM TAX WILL
GO BACK INTO RECESS. WE'RE
WAITING FOR ONE AUTHOR. WHEN
THAT AUTHOR ARRIVES, WE'LL COME
OUT OF RECESS.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON REVENUE
TAX WILL COME TO ORDER, AND WE
WILL REOPEN THE ROLL ON THE
BILLS FOR OUR ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND OUR FIRST ITEM WILL BE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR, WHICH CONTAINS
ITEMS ONE ITEMS. NINE AND ITEMS
11. SO, CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ON CONSENT CALENDAR. MOTION IS
ADOPT THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATORS ASHBY. ASHBY I8720. ALL
RIGHT. WE WILL NEXT GO TO ITEM
TWO, WHICH WAS PULLED FROM
CONSENT. THAT IS AB 1973 CALLED
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
520 WITH CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATOR ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE. SKINNER 6 TO 0.
GREAT THEN WE WILL GO TO ITEM
THREE AB 2061 CALLED THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. OH, I'M SORRY. DID I
SAY THAT THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WAS OUT? I YEAH, I THOUGHT YOU
DID. OKAY, GOOD. SO ITEM, AB
1973 IS OUT THE, THE VOTE WAS
5060. ALL JI'S VOTE WAS SIX
ZERO. NOW WE WILL GO TO, AB
2061. WOULD YOU CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS? MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 620 WITH CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR. ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE 7 TO
0. ALL RIGHT. AB 2061 IS OUT.
VOTE IS 7 TO 0. WE'LL GO TO ITEM
FOR AB 3259. MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR. CURRENT
VOTE IS 521 WITH CHAIR VOTING
AYE. VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. NO.
SENATOR ASHBY. I'M SORRY. WHAT
NUMBER WAS IT? THREE TWO. FIVE
NINE. WILSON ASHBY. AYE 621 AB
3259 IS OUT. 6 TO 1. NOW WE'LL
GO TO ITEM FIVE AB 2238. THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. NO VOTE RECORDED
FOR THE CHAIR OR VICE CHAIR.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0.
SENATORS. GLAZER DOLLY ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE. PADILLA 4 TO 0. AB
2238 IS OUT 4 TO 0. NOW WE'LL GO
TO AB 2353, ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD
CALLED THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
6 TO 0, WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR ASHBY.
ASHBY AYE. 7 TO 0, AB 2353 IS
OUT. VOTE IS 7 TO 0. WE'LL GO
NOW TO ITEM SEVEN AB 2443,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO CALLED
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. CURRENT VOTE IS 5 TO
1 WITH CHAIR VOTING AYE. VICE
VICE CHAIR VOTING NO. SENATOR
ASHBY. ASHBY. I'M 621 AB 2443 IS
OUT 6 TO 1. WE'LL NOW GO TO ITEM
EIGHT AB 2555 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA. CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 6 TO 0 WITH
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR. ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE. 7 TO
0. AB 2555 IS OUT 7 TO 0. WE'LL
NOW GO TO ITEM TEN AB 2854.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN. MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
6 TO 0 WITH CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATOR. ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE 7 TO 0. AB 2854 IS
OUT. THAT VOTE IS 7 TO 0. WILL
NOW MOVE TO AB OR SORRY TO ITEM
12 AB 3134 ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 6 TO 0 WITH
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR ASHBY. ASHBY I'M 7 TO 0.
AB 3134 IS OUT. VOTE IS 7 TO 0.
WILL NOW GO TO THE LAST ITEM.
ITEM 13 AB 3160 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL. MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
6 TO 0 WITH CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATOR. ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE 7 TO 0. THAT BILL IS
OUT. THE VOTE IS 7 TO 0. AND
WITH THAT, THE BUSINESS OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON REVENUE TAX
IS CONCLUDED.